foreign
[Music]
Parish Council so I shall we withdraw
for item six
thank you
[Music]
uh we now move uh to our meeting held on
Tuesday the 25th of July
um with regards to the minutes of the
last meeting are we happy they are a
correct record is there a mover
second that
all those in favor
any abstentions
the motion is carried
all right thank you Phillies that brings
us to the main business of the meeting
our three applications before we start I
would like
to I would like the Clark to explain for
the benefit of member speakers and those
watching on YouTube how we will deal
with them
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting
there will be speakers on the first and
second applications
speakers will have three minutes to put
forward their views
they'll be a reminder given by the clerk
when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting but they will not be allowed
to participate for participate further
from this point
the chair will then open up the meeting
for questions to officers a debate by
the committee and finally determination
on the application by arose
the votes will be taken by roll call
family members this meeting is being
live streamed and recording will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you chair
thank you
let's move on to the first application
Ned 22 stroke zero zero six eight six
stroke FL drumfield
in line with our normal practices I'm
going to ask the planning officer as to
tell us about the any late comment and
to give a brief presentation showing any
photos and plans of the site I will
allow the officers to complete their
presentation
consequently members unless you have a
point of order that you feel cannot wait
could you please reserve these or any
questions about the process until the
end
all right thank you I'll pass over to
Alice lucky tubes doing our first
presentation today
planning application for the development
of 27 New dwellings a sports Pavilion an
Associated access at land of Oak Hill
Road dronfield this is a major
development and we have
um to amend the title and her demanded
drawings during the application process
and the late representations were sent
to you yesterday I do have a slight
update on Boundary treatments which I'll
cover in my presentation if that's okay
sure
[Music]
the site outlined here in Orange is
located within the settlement
development limits for dronfield which
is a level one town and therefore
considered one of the most sustainable
settlements in the district the site is
not otherwise allocated in the local
plan for development
the site formally housed the Gladys
Buxton adult education center which was
demolished in 2019. it is bounded by the
doctor's surgery near the entrance
dwellings on Oak Hill Road back onto the
site to the north and to the south and
east is a playing field you can also see
the rectangular paved area to the South
which serves as a parking for the
playing fields this is not located
within the application site it is
considered that this area could
accommodate at least 75 cars
this is the red line plan for the
application site
part of the site shown here hatch brown
is included in the Brownfield register
and is therefore considered suitable for
redevelopment
the remainder of the site is is
designated as sports facilities shown
here in green the surrounding Sports
pictures provide one adult and one
year's football pitch
this area is protected by local and
National policy which seeks to protect
and enhance all existing sports and
recreation facilities
sport England originally objected to the
loss of the designated area within the
red line and the changing rooms
after some research and discussions for
England is accepted that the former
tennis court to the south of the
application site has been in use as a
car park for over 20 years and would be
sufficient to serve the remaining
playing fields
to mitigate the loss of the other areas
of the sports site and the changing
facilities the applicant has agreed to
include a two-team changing Pavilion in
the scheme the management of this
building will be secured as part of the
section 106 legal agreement
as a consequence sport England have
removed their objection
officers are therefore of the view that
the principle of development on this
site is acceptable
after negotiation with officers the
layout has been adjusted to meet many of
the criteria of good design outlined in
successful places
features outward facing design
terminating views and sufficient parking
mostly located to the side or rear of
the properties a mixture of two three
and four bed houses are proposed
of designs based on standard house types
interest is created by varied use of
materials and fenestration details
after having questions from Neighbors
about the boundary between the site and
the rear Gardens of Oak Hill Road I have
saw Clarity from the agent who informed
me yesterday that the vegetation on this
boundary will be cut back and a 1.8
meter high fence installed officers are
of the understanding that the trees
shown in the drawing will be retained if
members are minded to approve the
application officers have recommended a
condition to provide further details on
Boundary treatments as well as a
landscaping scheme which includes tree
protection measures
the following slides show the house
types
so I'm just going to go through these
quite quickly that's the three a three
birds semi-detached
another three buds semi-detached
uh three bed semi-detached with a garage
two birds semi-detached
sorry too many pieces of paper
um
a four bed detached
in it and it's located at the center of
the site
and then most of the um the plots also
have garages either single or double
um or
um groups of garages
this photo is taken from the southeast
the application site is the raised area
to the right of the picture with
existing adjoining doctor surgery in the
background the sports Pavilion will be
located approximately where the tree is
in the center of this photo stand
this photo is taken from within the site
the photo shows that the adjoining
properties on Oak Hill Road to the north
are located at a higher elevation than
the application site the levels of
elevation decreased from east to west
this is a view of the north east and
under the site from the playing fields
this is the center of the site from the
playing fields you can see an existing
boundary features with the dwellings on
Oak Hill Road
um and the view from the former tennis
courts parking narrative site at the
proposed Pavilion overall an on balance
officers consider that the proposal of
this design and layout in in a
sustainable location is acceptable and
are therefore recommending approvals
subject to conditions and the completion
of a full section 106 agreement the
legal agreement will include but is not
limited to provision of affordable
housing management of the sports
Pavilion and biodiversity Net game
provision
and that's everything thank you chair
thank you Alex
uh right colleagues we have three
speakers on the application the first
two of whom is Elizabeth Ransom an
objector uh there will each have three
minutes to get over their points and
will be informed when they have 30
seconds remain
uh as members you can ask uh to clarify
any matters that are being raised but
remember your questions should only
relate to the point which they have
already made
uh can we have the first speaker please
um yeah I don't no problem with that
so it's Paul Ransom
thank you
yeah that's no problem so you've got
you've got three minutes Paul if you
understood that um thank you
um so we just wanted to raise a couple
of important questions really regarding
the proposed development of the Gladys
books and site firstly
um regarding the co-authority's comments
of the risk of gas emissions just
stating that the local planning
authorities should seek their own
technical advice on the gas hazards that
may exist and appropriate measures be
implemented from technically competent
personnel and can we have assurances
that this will be the case and that we
as interested parties will be able to
view any reports in a transparent and
open way such as email notification when
reports submitted to planning officials
um or the council and secondly can I ask
the the remediation and mitigation
measures regarding one stability are
also made available to interested
parties and so that we can ensure there
are no negative impacts to surrounding
houses
um
and then my final
um note would be to draw attention
really to the committee and the council
is that
um the current state of the playing
fields is not fit for purpose and they
need considerable work uh so the
provision of sports Pavilion
um would increase the use of this area
for sport and exercise which would be a
positive thing uh however as others have
commented I think in the comments uh
only if we have assurances that the
necessary work will be done to address
the state of the playing fields area
safe provision of parking as well as the
ongoing maintenance and monitoring of
this area as a Community Asset
thank you thank you
do any members have any questions
at Council Cooper
good afternoon afternoon
um I'm just on the stage of the actual
football fields how many is there just
to clarify uh there's actually three
pictures but I believe that was in in
the comments it was one adult and one
Junior but um I mean we both run
regularly in the area we'd never run on
that field it's not it's not safe it's
uh there's the the state of the fields
now is just um it's an outfit for it
okay and how often is it used and are
the teams actually who are playing on
there I presume there are teams are they
part of leagues there aren't any teams
playing on there that I'm aware of no
not for and for many years and basically
I think the grass has just been caught
and it was it was wild and overgrown and
if you look at the goal posts they're
rusted and and have just been left for
years so I don't believe there's been
any maintenance to that site for a long
time really in terms of football pitches
a new actually maintains a great who
actually maintains that that Sports area
uh well I assume it was established
you're going to council or drumfield
Town Council but I don't I'm not
actually aware of who's responsible for
it to be honest it used to be maintained
and for a number of years after the
school was demolished and the um the
education center was there they were
maintained to a decent level uh and you
did have teams training on them
okay thank you very much
nobody else
okay uh thank you you can see it again
I'll call Elizabeth Branson
thank you whenever you're ready okay
thanks thank you hi everybody
um I'm pleased to see you in the revised
plan that the trees hedgerows and
vegetation around the edge are remaining
as these have been there for many years
and would seriously impact the wildlife
and well-being of people who live on the
road if they were removed
um but I'm just worried about well what
sort of assurance and legal requirement
will take place to ensure that
building contractors don't damage trees
or remove vegetation I unders which will
disturb wildlife and nesting Birds
during the building work
and the plans describe and justify the
interaction to the existing houses in
section two four in the revised planning
statement as the site being
in quotation separated by a steep
embankment which leads up from the site
to the rear Gardens of the properties
along Oak Hill Road in most instances
the back Gardens are defined by a
significant level of trees and
vegetation which physically separates
the site from the rear Gardens of the
adjoining houses end of quotations is
correct in most instances the back
Gardens do have trees and vegetation
separating them from the proposed site
however not all the houses have a state
bank as you said earlier it does
it does taper off
on one side so it's not not much of a
steep Bank there is a bit of a bank but
it's not I won't describe it as as a
steep Bank there and
my interest is clock 16 looks very close
to the end of our garden and next door
and
seems to have an open boundary
so
I'm concerned a couple of things that
concern me about plot 16 in particular
on the new design is it's going to
impinge on our privacy
and possibly light due to Elevation and
design of the planned house that's one
of the larger ones in relation to our
garden and house
um
so because the boundary is open I'm
concerned that the existing vegetation
won't be protected as stated in the plan
because if the so that was my
comments really about it
okay thank you very much does uh anybody
have any questions
nope you can
you can take back to your seat then
please thank you thank you
[Music]
we now have um Tom broslin who is the
agent
if you'd like to take care take a seat
please
thank you whenever you're ready
thanks chair and good afternoon all I'm
Tom breezing from a banner sound
planning the agent for this application
I'd like to begin by reflecting on
what's been a very thorough and highly
collaborative application process the
scheme before you today is the products
of significant engagement with the
council's planning team and consulties
to get to this point of an office
recommendation for approval is a
significant achievement and the credit
of both the applicant and your offices
who have been cooperative and robust
throughout
it's the fair belief of the applicant
that this scheme represents the best
outcome for the site and locality
bringing forward a development on
Brownfield and of a suitable density
providing much needed new homes to
respond to acute local need
The Proposal is fully affordable housing
policy compliant with affordable units
the affordable units to be provided as
affordable rented as requested by the
local authorities housing team
the applicant is also committed to meet
the full complement of section 106
requirements
the provision of a brand new sports
Pavilion with changing the shell
facilities for use by local sports teams
will anchor the development in the
community and provide a significant new
Community Asset that will enable the
continued development of local talent
and drive Sports participation
through cooperation with your officers
this scheme has also been significantly
reduced from an originally proposed 35
units to the 27 unit schemes you see
before you today
this process of iterative redesign has
resulted in a scheme which has achieved
the best possible layout with homes that
interacts with the open space and each
other according to the principles
outlined within the council's SPG on
successful places
from a highways perspective the
transport assessment has demonstrated to
the satisfaction of the highways officer
how the busy times have used for the
very few various different users of the
site that share the access will
fundamentally not clash with the
proposed
development
most concentrated trips during the
working hours of the week and the sports
pitches and changing facilities
generating their most concentrated trips
on weekends
therefore highways the highways officer
is satisfied that the users combined
will not overwhelm The Junction with
local Road
the applicant is currently finalizing
biodist net gain Arrangements while
whilst off-site on site by the base net
gain isn't feasible despite extensive
Landscaping entry retention efforts an
off-site solution at thriftwood is being
explored upon Derbyshire County
council's Guidance the applicant is
committed to our site
business
anybody given the context of a
nationwide housing crisis that is felt
particularly acutely in drum field
preventing money from accessing
sustainability settings left
particularly young families in need of
affordable rent
the positive contribution of that this
fully affordable housing policy
compliance proposal will have in this
regard cannot be understated and
therefore thank your officers again for
working with us to ensure the quality
and thoroughness of the scheme and I
strongly urge members to support the
recommendation for approval thank you
uh thank you uh do any members of any uh
questions or points Clarity for the uh
agent
uh
absolutely Cooper
um I have some concerns about the new
sports Pavilion
um from what I've heard earlier there's
no teams actually
based on that side because the pitches
are just not of the fit state to be able
to play football or other sports on by
the sound of it I mean they've even uh
just the the two early speaks have
described the fact that they don't even
run on there because it's not fit for
that
um do you propose to do any work to them
Sports you talk about encouraging sport
which I fully endorse you talk about
talent I fully endorse all that
but without the actual facilities
and the teams
there's no there's no future there and
you've got a building that could it
effectively become a real problem to
that area uh it needs some ownership and
it and it needs some it needs some sort
of thinking about I think before you
just
before we put a sports uh Pavilion up
changing facility call it what you will
without the necessary
um
main thing in order I.E the playing
field
and the fact that people will use it as
it's meant to be used for and and take
some responsibility onto that building
and and what's more then we need to be
assured about the ownership of that
building
um so as as Alice mentioned the the
ownership will be secured as part of the
section 106. and the applicant's
currently in discussions with Derbyshire
County Council who uh own uh the owner
of the the sports pitch adjacent to our
size that's not actually within our site
boundary
um but the ongoing discussions that will
be secured through the section 106 with
between the agent and Derbyshire County
Council will but essentially work all
the work out who will be responsible for
the maintenance of the of this of the
sports Pavilion
um the pitches are within the site
boundary the the reason for the sports
William was a sport England objection
um in order to remove the sport England
objection they requested the provision
of the equivalent facilities that were
lost when the score was demolished in
um so that's the reason for the
provision of the sports Pavilion and
maintenance will be will be discussed as
part of the social model six discussions
with Derbyshire County Council
okay
Council again
thank you
it's probably more appropriate actually
to ask Alice but I'll ask I'll ask
anyway because I've been told today that
Derbyshire County Council have
categorically said they do not want
ownership of that Sports Pavilion so
basically a sports Pavilion is being
built with no owners
and nobody to run it thank you
any more questions
bye thank you you can yeah I think um
the as I say that the reason for the
Pavilion being there was the sport
England objection
um the the discussions that the African
is having and we'll be sort of concerned
with the tied into this session 106. uh
it's not necessarily for Derbyshire
County Council to to take over ownership
is to find out who will own it you know
it's it's it's it's not it's an
discussion that's ongoing
um I'm not aware that there's been some
complimental finalization as you say at
the moment
um but it it will have to be worked out
as part of the section 106 that this
application is is hinging upon
essentially
thank you
right
um right colleagues we'll now move on to
the questions for officers uh which I'm
sure that will might be one of them
um as always I would uh like to keep
this part of the preceding focus on
getting clarity about any point you are
not sure of once we have done this we
can then have our discussion about the
application based on all that we have
heard and read
um
thank you
um can I please have my comments uh
minuteed because it concerns me greatly
this because I can just see this
building becoming an anti-social
um hot spot shall we call it uh because
as it is at the moment they're putting a
building up and there's absolutely
nobody there's no team there's no
committees
there's not the County Council there's
nobody to run it so basically there's
just going to be a white elephant
building in a muddy field
so was there a question there
okay thank you
thank you Council again
the the if if members of minded to Grant
permission today it will be subject to
the section 106 agreement so
um if agreement can't be made about the
uh management of the sports Pavilion
then the permission
won't exist
um so in my view that is it we won't end
up with a white elephant because we have
to get that sorted out before the
decision can be but before the
development can go ahead
if I can add to that chair that as Alice
says the recommendation before you is to
Grant permissions subject to that 106
agreement for which this would form a
part so if that wasn't achieved we would
need to find a way of addressing that
and that may and bringing that about to
yourselves because without the Pavilion
provision that additional offsetting
facility the comments and concerns of
sport England may may become relevant
again so we would have to find a way
through that if we couldn't achieve that
through the 106 agreement
uh thank you for clarifying that any
further questions from officers
councilor Cooper
thanks Jeff uh thanks for clarifying
that because that is a definite point to
a concern for myself as well
um
my next question is regarding uh the
comments made by Mrs Ranson regarding
the boundary treatment at 16.
um
can you just clarify what what the
situation is there please
is slightly closer to the boundary uh
than we would normally expect from
um
from the uh the guidance from successful
places however uh the way that the uh
the the house has been designed
um the there are no overlooking with
first floor Windows
um that are within 10.5 meters of the
boundary
um and as I uh made and pointed out in
um in my in my presentation earlier
um there is actually going to be a a
fence along that boundary so any sort of
ground floor windows will not will be
blocked by that
um so we are of the view that although
it it's not 100 meeting uh successful
place is the the applicants of of
through the design have addressed the
concerns
um so we're we're that is therefore
acceptable
thank you
any more questions for officers Council
Cooper
um just a couple just going back to the
um
the changing facility I just want to
clarify because obviously not knowing
the site
is there access to the changing facility
from the existing car park and also is
there access onto the onto the actual
playing fields
from the changing facility without
actually going back onto the car park is
that attained so what I wouldn't want to
see is people
children particularly running back down
over the car park potentially with with
cars maneuvering parking Etc
and would it be helpful if I showed you
the drawing again yep if you can bring
that up again please
I'm just going to zip back through
okay
um so the the changing Pavilion will be
there at the bottom oh I shared that
okay yeah
um it's the long building at the bottom
of the site
um the area that can be used as car park
is this whole area of former tennis
courts it's a really large area I think
it's something like 90 meters long by
about 30 meters wide so as you can see
there is access to it from The Pavilion
and access across to the playing field
which are sort of to the um to the east
is not without going across that piece
of land
but I can't see why it wouldn't be
possible to manage it in such a way that
you wouldn't have cars along that top
that top boundary at the minute this is
not laid out with any parking it's not
got like parking lines or anything
but I can't see why there wouldn't be a
possibility for that to happen and for
to be able to manage in a reasonable way
could could that form part of the
condition if subject to the 106 going
through could that form part of the
condition that we make some access
no
no I don't think the only um suggestion
I've got chairs if that were um a
particular concern to members that
potentially something that could be
included in the management of the
Pavilion and be including a 106
agreement I think that would be the my
suggested Way Forward if that was a
concern to you
it is a concern because it's an health
and safety issue as far as I'm concerned
I wouldn't want people running back onto
that area
obviously there's a green area within
the boundary
is there no way that that could be used
as part of it
the there are two ways chair that um
it's planning committee are concerned
about that and would wish to Grant
permissions subject to that is to either
impose a condition requiring some some
walkway from The Pavilion that avoids
the car park or as I say included in the
management agreement and I'm sure one of
those would be appropriate and I I think
um would be covered by the
recommendation before you as officers we
would note at that point and address it
either by way of conditional through the
106 agreement to ensure that there is no
that there is access from the new
Pavilion building to the playing fields
that doesn't need to go through areas
where cars are parked I think that that
I think that encapsulates what your
consumers
canceling it
um Adrian I'm just still a bit a little
confused if if
part of the 106 agreement and there is
no management
how how do we move forward
Alice has been
bodies out apologize I don't know the
exact same people you've been talking to
but we are aware that there is
certainly advised towards not in writing
but in in verbal form a latent demand
for an area such as this for the use by
sports teams within dronfield and as Mr
Mr Bryson said to you that doesn't
necessarily mean that the County Council
need to take the building on it could be
a another but that would be something
that would be addressed through
completion of the 106 agreement so there
would be some ownership of the building
achieved through that and then that
would be ongoing thereafter
the the issue that we've had as planners
is that there was a against Mr Mr Bryson
and Alice have both mentioned there was
a
objection from sport England which in
effect was something that had to be
addressed by the applicant and the local
planning Authority in conjunction to
move forwards and as officers we've
secured what is deemed to be an
appropriate mitigating provision because
the change of facilities used to be
within the adult education center and
they were lost when the building was
lost so in effect to
promote the ReUse of the playing area
and I know what's been said to you in by
speakers and by councilor Cooper that
the facilities as they are maybe need
some work on them but to secure the
long-term use of the plane facilities a
changing area was something that
I think it was the fa and the football
Foundation required and this is the
solution that's been found and is
planning Authority we believe that this
meets your policy objectives with regard
to the retention of a sports Area sports
pitches which is designated in your
local plan this is one of those and it's
the
outcome that we as planning officers
feel
happy with and we can recommend to you
approval of the scheme subject to the
provision of this as we keep on going
back to the
management and ownership of that
facility doesn't need to be the County
Council or necessarily fake housed it
could be a private body or a football
club for example but that would be
addressed through the section 106
agreement
no more questions officers right thank
you for officers
um this is the final part of the process
our discussion about what we've heard
what we think and what we want to decide
but before we go any further I would
like the clerk to remind us about
motions
thank you chair
please bear in mind members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
second is
then that Amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer's recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reason for moving emotion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by evidence as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls
or in other words it is not past
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you'll need to take a positive
decision
through a further motion
in favor of the recommend a to be
approved by the committee through
another vote thank you
thank you for that one
uh right I would like two of them before
for debate
thank you chair
um I mean I've been on here a long time
and I think this is probably the only
application I've seen in years that
actually has the housing
supportive I think it's it's a little
bit worrying that sport England have put
this condition on that we've got to meet
in there but I agree with the word I
think Alice has done a sterling job
actually again getting that sorted my
only concern with it is is the plot 16
issue but again it seems as though
everything that can be done to mitigated
has been done so I'm I'm part supportive
of this one
thank you
Council ticket
I'm gonna agree I mean I'm quite happy
about the proposal it's just that I do
think it's irresponsible to
put a building up with no management
already you know wanting it as it were
because I just I'm just very very
concerned that that Sports Pavilion
could end up as like I say am
anti-social Behavior area uh
just just trying to to reassure members
on this point chair that planning
permission
won't won't be granted if you are minded
to resolve this afternoon to Grant
permission it won't be granted
until unless a section 106 agreement
that secures the ongoing management of
the building has been secured and as I
said earlier chair if if the resolution
is based on that and that's not
addressed and secured we would need to
find a way of moving forward and that
may mean coming back to yourselves for a
reassessment of of the application and
all that that entails because there is
the sporting good issue so as best I can
chair I'm trying to reassure members
that thank you there won't be a building
constructed without that being secured
thank you for clarifying that area
and the other comments anybody else nope
all right thank you colleagues uh I've
been heard everything today and the
officer recommendations before us uh
what is the view of the community on the
application I am now opening the floor
to motions
I'm happy to move that we accept office
and recommendations chair second nature
thank you second of our counselor house
right I'll take a vote on that and I'm
sure it runs please
whatever accepting off the
recommendations yeah
that's too unanimous sure
yep
sorry um
if you would like to leave now and we
need to bring some more people in for
the next debate thank you
thank you for your participation thanks
uh it's just going to take a few minutes
while I bring the uh there's quite a few
speakers on the next item so we need to
bring those into the chamber
foreign
application
which is Ned 23 stroke zero zero six one
zero stroke FL cutthorpe
I'm going to ask the planning officers
to tell us about any late comments and
to give a brief presentation showing any
photos and plans of the site
I will allow the officers
your feelings about the process until
the end
thank you uh pass you over to Alice
again who's going to do the second
presentation thanks
foreign
this application is for temporary
planning permission for sighting of a
mobile phone shop and Cafe creation of
new access and parking at land to the
west side of cutthorpe Institute main
road
um the late reps were sent to you
yesterday but we have just at five past
12 uh this afternoon received comments
from highways which in summary have no
objection subject to conditions with
regard to parking visibility supplies
and pedestrian visibility supplies
the application site is shown here in
Orange
the site is located outside of the
settlement development limits and is
therefore in the Northeast Derbyshire
Green Belt the site is also within the
primary area of multiple environmental
sensitivity or the aims
and this is therefore considered to be
in part of the district's most valued
landscapes
in the green belt inappropriate
development should not be approved
except in very special circumstances the
construction of new buildings is
regarded as inappropriate development
with some exceptions agricultural
buildings are considered an exception
however offices are of the view that as
the building will not be used for an
Agricultural purpose is located well
away from the other buildings
constituting the primary farm group and
The Works required to establish it are
considerable and permanent in character
and as such it cannot be classed as
either an agricultural building or a
temporary structure ancillary to the
farm operation
as a consequence The Proposal does not
meet any of the exceptions
a location plan is outlined here in red
the block plan shows the building
located approximately 30 meters from The
Institute with a car parking area for 10
cars laid to hard standing in between a
new access within the existing dry stone
wall will be created to Main Road
engineering works such as to form a car
park may be acceptable in the green belt
provided they preserve the openness of
the green belt and do not conflict with
its purposes
offices are of the view that such an
area of hard standing and wide access
point would both individually and
collectively fail to preserve the
spatial and visual openness and would
have an urbanizing impact on the green
belt
as a whole officers consider the
proposals to harm the green belt and
therefore it requires very special
circumstances for its approval
the building proposed is a modular
building which has the character of a
mobile home officers consider that it
fails to meet the high standard of
design required by the council's
countryside landscape and design
policies and would be harmful to the
valued landscape
the following photos are a selection
from yesterday's site visit
the site is currently an open arable
field there are no existing buildings
within the field
the site forms the setting of Coronation
tree seen here in the foreground this is
a locally important Green Space as
identified in the emerging neighborhood
plan you can see that the site will be
clearly visible from the Green Space
the cup thought
area Hall a grade 2 listed building can
be seen in the distance in these photos
in this photo
when viewed from the settlement the
field as a whole provides an attractive
setting to the edge of the village and
when looking towards the conservation
area officers consider it to have an
urbanizing impact on the views into the
Conservation Area
this is a view looking back
towards from from the West
officers consider that the proposal
would represent inappropriate
development which would by definition
harm the green belt it is also
considered that due to the design and
sighting of the building and parking
design and sighting the building and
parking would harm the character of the
valued landscape the applicants and
supporters have put forward what they
consider to be very special
circumstances including the need for a
local shop in the village however
offices are of the view that they hope
they hold little weight as they are in
most instances unsubstantiated and in
any case do not outweigh the significant
harm identified
added to this it is considered that
design and sighting of the building and
Associated development is not informed
by or sympathetic to the distinctive
landscape character or primary area of
multiple environmental sensitivity it
would also impact dry Stonewall and a
green space and would therefore fail to
meet National local and emerging
neighborhood neighborhood plan policy
thank you chair
uh thank you Alice uh right colleagues
we are with 11 speakers now on this
application uh the first of whom is
Andrew Arrington an objector
um they will each have three minutes to
get over their points and they will be
informed when they have 30 seconds left
uh you can ask them to clarify matters
that have been raised but remember your
questions should relate to the points
which they have already made
speakers joining us by the teams I
believe Andrew Arrington
thank you hello
yeah thank you thank you you've got
three minutes thank you thank you thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak to you today I like several others
I'm opposed to the application and I
hope you will support your planning
officer who is recommended refusal on
planning grounds
is a ribbon development on the edge of
Britain's first national park and the
proposed neighborhood plan of Brampton
Parish Council if adopted will and I
quote ensure any new development
requires no intrusion into the green
belt and respects distinctive character
individuality and setting an open
Countryside this development clearly
does not meet that test support for this
application is considerable if largely
unfocused some support is from
non-residents many of these responses
can be paraphrased as a good idea and
deserving to succeed but without
planning Merit supporters are making
much of a need for the cafe and farm
shop in the village perhaps we're
getting the lateral spread of cutthop
over a three mile stretch of road to
many residents this shop and Cafe will
never be local also forgotten is the
fact that there was at one time a corner
shop a butcher shop and a post office in
the village all of which are no more and
can I mention here that what I believe
is the Caravan that will be used as the
shop stroke Cafe has been delivered to
the woods Farm it could be that
applicants have already taken your
approval for granted thank you for
listening to me today I hope you will
make your decision solely on the
planning aspects of the application and
nothing else thank you
um have any members got any questions
about the points the speaker was raced
nope all right we'll move straight on to
the second speaker uh which is Elizabeth
Wood the applicant
if you have three minutes
um if you press the microphone on like
that yeah thank you
dear chairman and committee I've lived
in cutthorp on our dairy farm for all my
life also I've got a food science and
nutrition degree it is one of the
applicants I'm deeply saddened to see
that the new jobs that are being
provided by the farm shop and cafe and
the same job that I'm currently doing
are seen as low skilled which I believe
is not the case
there are many skills needed to provide
the high level of food safety and
customer service which we are intending
to provide at the farm shop as well as
this we are wanting our staff to be able
to complete many jobs not just cooking
or waitressing we are hoping that they
will be able to pasteurize in the dairy
on the farm as well as make the ice
cream and other dairy products including
yogurt and cheese which we are hoping to
sell
I don't know about you but I wouldn't
want someone low skill producing the
food I'm going to eat the employment of
locals will mean that they can socialize
with the other people in the village
meaning that there is a homely feel
which we hope to portray
it's a local Hub that we are wanting to
provide to the village is a much needed
necessity that the upcoming neighborhood
plan mentions a village shop is second
on the villagers list and the cafe is
fourth
they cements the fact that the village
wants it with even our object to say and
they would still use it
if this was placed at the farm it would
alienate a lot of the elderly residents
who are unable to drive or have mobility
issues meaning the Endeavor will not be
successful leading on from this the shop
will not provide us
um leading on from this the shop will
not only provide us with another place
to sell our farm produce but also
products from surrounding Farmers
meaning we can Source around 80 of our
produce from locals
we already have a vending machine
selling our pasteurized milk on the farm
however we we have had people contact us
saying that it should be in a central
Village location that is easier to get
through get to as well as this we've had
complaints stating that it's dangerous
with the constant Farm traffic this
provides reasoning why the farm shop on
the farm will be unsuitable as it is
hard to get to and people would not want
to walk that distance with all the
shopping
all the shopping okay
the long Farm Lane that is needed to get
down is a single track that is also a
bridal way and footpath meaning that the
increased traffic volume will become a
danger to them I urge you the committee
to consider the point I have raised and
approve the application to create a
Village Farm Shopping Cafe for the
locals to use together with the car park
for customers and The Institute users
thank you
thank you uh do any members have any
questions
about the points that have been raised
yes
um so with the building it's currently
open plan so um if the farm Shop's more
viable we'll we'll extend it further
into the room and if the cafe is more
viable we'll extend that so it depends
what's best for the village
Council Cooper
it's already been sorted
now for the questions you can see thank
you
the third speaker we have is also the
applicant Matthew Langley
all right Matthew three minutes whenever
you're ready thank you dear Champion
committee I'm Matthew one of the
applicants a member of the chartered
Institute of Management accountants I'm
here today to talk about the unit itself
and the temporary nature of this we
applied for a three-year temporary
permission with the view to prove the
viability to the community without them
committing to a permanent Endeavor on
the sides therefore we believe that
during the three years we can prove that
the land is more viable to the community
it's a farm shop and Cafe than as the
corner of the field
the proposed site currently takes up
half a percent of the total field volume
The Wildflower Meadow which we've given
up takes up significant significantly
More Than This the whole building has
been designed and approved the British
standards as a caravan to allow it to be
reinstated as a field in a matter of
hours if the farm shop proves
unsuccessful the unit itself is
comprised in two sections which yes have
already been delivered both on wheeled
steel chassis and they've got a tow
hitch at the front and can be towed by
four by fours which is the way they
ended up getting put where they are they
are joined together by
12 volts remain on Wheels and Axle samp
stands one-sided units are cladded
externally with a composite dark wood
cladding and gray window surrounds all
you need to reduce the impact and ensure
it remains looking like a Farm building
the units are well insulated and
equipped with air heat pumps for Energy
Efficiency waste towards is collected in
a tank to be pumped away and a temporary
temporary Electric electrical collection
has already been quoted for by the
National Grid with the view of it being
disconnected and decommissioned at the
end of the three years the car park is a
crushed stone layer placed on a membrane
this will ensure that no impact to the
road parking is created and will also
aim to improve Park in the local Village
by allowing the village Institute users
who currently do not have a car park so
where to park safely so they're not
blocking the bend this application was
strongly supported by the Institute
management committee for use of the car
park and has also been supported by the
parish council at the end of the three
years the car park will be removed in a
matter of hours not days with our
standard farm machinery the drystone
wall will be rebuilt by the farm
drystone Waller and there'll be no
evidence of the shop ever being there if
should the project fail the shock can be
fully removed and the green belt
reinstated therefore there's no lasting
harm to the green belt we believe that
the temporary permission will allow us
to prove the viability and
sustainability and diversification of
the farm as Farmers we're always being
told back to diversify that's exactly
what we're trying to do with this
application
when looking to diversify we set out to
engage with local residents by holding a
stall at the Village event and talking
to lots of groups to find out what was
required from the village
where they wanted and required by most
residents we're humbled by the support
we've received from the village and we
strongly hope you consider supporting
the farm and the village of this
application thank you
thank you do any members have any
questions about the points that they
nope right we'll move on to the next
speaker
which is the agent Dominic Cooney
and you've only got three minutes thank
you thank you chairman
I'm Dominic Cooney a chartered Town
planner working for bagshaws and I'm
speaking as the agent for the
application
we are disappointed to see the
recommendation for refusal the
applicants have proposed in this
application a farm shop with the lowest
impact possible using a mobile building
and a temporary permission that is
easily reversible
I'd like to draw the committee's
attention to the key aspects of this
application the reversibility of what is
proposed here the officer's report is
somewhat misleading in this respect but
the simple facts are as follows the
building meets the definition of a
caravan and can be installed or removed
in a day
the parking area will be crushed stone
laid on a geotextile membrane
so that it is entirely reversible
and dry stone walls are easy to
dismantle and rebuild at any time indeed
this goes on all the time on farms
across the land
the location for this building is not in
any area identified as a distinctive
view in the neighborhood plan
and I feel that the officer's report is
somewhat misleading again in this
respect
it can be seen in the visualization
submitted that the building itself sits
very low in the landscape
the design of the building Timber
cladding with a corrugated roof is
typical of agricultural buildings Timber
sheds are very common on farms any other
materials such as brick or concrete
block would be used for a permanent
building but this is not a permanent
building
the main group of farm buildings is down
Green Lane and unmade road is also a
public Bridal way
and is well inside the cutthorpe
Conservation Area
we consider this to be a much better
position than located right next to the
farm because of the issues down there
and the conflicts between Walkers and
horse riders that use Green Lane
the committee members will have noted on
the file the numerous letters of support
which far outweigh the small handful of
negative comments
as Matthew already pointed out the
parish council support the application
stating that it enjoys strong local
support particularly given that there
has not been a local shop for many years
which was highlighted in the Brampton
neighborhood plan and the opportunity to
purchase locally sourced produce from a
local Outlet is a sustainable benefit
and would have a positive impact on
reducing carbon emissions through
decreased food miles
so if planning system can also call a
local farm with such high levels of
support from residents and the parish
council 30 seconds remain then what
either happened to the localism ACT
we respectfully ask the committee to
approve this application today so that
Lizzie and Matthew and the rest of the
Wood family can secure the future of
their farming Enterprise in cupboard
thank you
uh thank you any members have any
questions about the points raised
councilor Falls
if you don't mind Dominic just want
I just want to refer back to one of the
officers a moment Dominic's touched on
something where we saw the um we saw the
visual earlier of the farm shop which is
sort of uh gray and blue and yellow yeah
Dominic has pointed out and it was in
some of the photos in the pack that this
can be clad with um with Timber
essentially
can we just double check that point that
that is because this contravening
information there
the cloud yes right okay
Dominic at the moment you uh I've seen
then I just assure you that it's not
going to be yellow and blue and yeah
that's a technical drawing yeah and that
they were in in the drawing Services
well no it's not even that color that's
just a technical drawing in with the
plans where the proper elevations
showing the timber cladding but
unfortunately they haven't been shown in
the presentation which I also feel is a
little bit misleading
thank you um so at the moment the dairy
farm dairy farms are struggling no
secret is that viable or not viable
without this Edition
it is viable at the moment but obviously
the milk price fluctuates wildly as our
speakers have already pointed out
and
we've got the next generation of our
passionate speakers the next generation
of farmers and they want to ensure that
the farm continues to operate and as
they've already pointed out
diversification is the key and to be
able to sell their product directly to
the end user will the dairy products
being sold in there be exclusively from
their Farm definitely right thank you
thanks
uh the next speaker we have is uh David
cotton a supporter
and you've got three minutes when you're
ready Davey thank you
Mr chairman of members of the planning
committee good afternoon I am as you
said David catton I've lived in
Cutthroat for almost 25 years
on receiving the officer's report a
group of cutthroat residents met to
discuss its contents we concluded that
in July the planning department quickly
concluded that the proposed location of
the farm shop was an incursion to the
green belt causing it harm in the
terminology of the national planning
policy framework so it must be rejected
in the ensuing two months the appointed
case officer trolled through the mppf
the national the local plan and the
Brampton Parish neighborhood plan and
the opposing comments to find examples
of texts that would justify a
recommendation to reject the application
we worked from the opposite starting
point to find evidence that justifies
approval of the application we've had
but a few days since obtaining the
officer's report to unravel it
and the relevant documents yesterday we
submitted our case in a late
representation which I hope you have all
taken the opportunity to read and Digest
we are not skilled people with
professional experience in extracting
arguments from the rules and regulations
relevant to planning decisions
nevertheless we've done our best and my
colleagues will now attempt to show that
fair-minded judges should conclude that
this application may be approved
in recent years this
Council has approved six planning
applications relating to farm shops
located in the NAD Greenbelt these
involve new build premises extensions
tool or changes to the use of existing
buildings improvements to access as well
as provision of or extensions to parking
or for Farm shops
on the northeast Derbyshire District the
green belt
we have also found elsewhere in England
planning approvals for developments on
Greenbelt Land for purposes that seem
totally inappropriate
these were approved because the relevant
planning authorities deemed in each case
the benefits to their local Society
outweighed the harm to the green belt
expressed by our poses
members of the committee it is in your
power to disagree with the officer's
recommendations and approve this
application
all we ask is that you listen to my
colleagues as they attempt to
demonstrate that there are Provisions in
the nppf the local plan and the
neighborhood plan
to justify your approval of this
application
thank you is there any members have any
questions
for the speaker
on the punches no
all right thank you if you like to
retake your seat
at the next speaker is going to be
joining us by teams and it's Andrew
Hughes another supporter
uh is Andrew use their Martin
foreign
otherwise it might be best for sure to
just move to the next speaker and then
see if he arrives and due course
right we'll move on to the next speaker
um which is uh Jane Johnston
this is actually Tom yourself
right thank you definitely it's
definitely not good after my wife is
working today
so good afternoon everybody a resident
my wife and I are resident in Cut but
I've been for about I think under 20
years as well and I just wanted to pick
up one of the key issues really is
around the game bit this being on
Greenbelt I'm just picking up the
comment in the officer's report it says
however it's not shown why the proposed
facility could not be located a women's
settlement or why Greenbelt location is
essential to provide this facility
in addition in granting a planning
consent the local planning Authority
could not guarantee that the site would
be used by other site owners for
purposes differing from these from those
set out by the applicant
officers conclude that the provision of
a shopping cart that would bring
Community benefits but there's no
overriding reason why a site within the
green bell is required to provide for it
I think your officer puts up a diagram
of cutthop and it is a long ribbon that
goes around the road and the settlement
area actually covers those buildings
that are in existence as they stand at
the moment outside of that is all the
green belt and the challenge that brings
is there is no area that is not already
populated with houses or whatever that
could be used for the the site which is
why that site's been chosen I think it
was either Andrew or Lizzy explained
very clearly that the existing facility
the farm and the rest of it is down
quite a long road which is quite
difficult to get access to so the the
point they're chosen is the best sort of
location you could put a shop in in
cupboard and unfortunately is on
Greenbelt but there is no area in the
settlement where you could put the shop
now that was the main point I think I
really wanted to get across the other
point around
um while the local the local planning
Authority can't guarantee that site will
not be used by other site owners no
actually I think the inference there is
you get scope you get other people
wanted to take on the green bill this is
on on the woods Farm you know they have
absolute control of this and there's no
attention I don't see any reason why so
the planning Authority wouldn't be able
to guarantee it but there's no reason
why the Woods Family actually there's no
incentive for them to go outside of this
and use the land for other areas
and I think really that was all I wanted
to say
uh thank you do any members have any
questions on the points raised no thank
you we'll move on to the next speaker uh
which is Andrew Wood
there's also a supporter of the scheme
I think you only got three minutes when
you're ready
thank you Mr chairman yeah good
afternoon everybody
um I'm actually the applicant's father
and the landowner I'm Dairy Farmer an
endangered species really uh over the
past two and a half years the number of
dairy farms in the UK has fallen from
ten thousand to seven and a half
thousand uh we currently milk about 130
dairy cows producing a million liters of
milk a year which at the moment is all
taken to droitwich to be processed and
brought back to God knows you know to
the rest of the country to wherever and
it's always seemed crazy to us that this
milk is getting all that distance to
come away again we're supposed to be
going carbon neutral aren't we we're
supposed to be net zero that's the thing
and so when Elizabeth came forward with
the proposal of what we were going to do
it made absolute sense to me that we
could protest the milk within a few
meters of where it comes out of the cow
and then we could literally sell it in
the village a few hundred meters up the
road the lane and
it just made absolute perfect sense you
know to do that we've got uh every year
we finish about 80 or 90 beef animals on
the on off the farm you know and again
they go to wherever you know why why
can't they be sold through the shop we
grow grass and cereals on the farm
there's no reason why we can't grow
other things we have land swap with the
neighborware he grows potatoes on some
of our land there's no reason why that
can't you know all these things that can
be done locally that people go
everywhere to Source I mean again we've
heard of how diversification is the way
forward well how are we supposed to
diversify if we're not allowed to
diversify I mean we we understand the
green belt but you've got to remember
that the farm itself Falls within the
conservation area and is in close
proximity to list of buildings
um and because of Green Lane and the
farm it's a busy working farm we have
two full-time sorry three others are
full-time on the farm and then there's
two part-time employees there's always
something happening to have cars coming
down down to a shop or whatever all the
time to you know he's not safe Farm's
got a terrible health and safety record
we don't need something to make that
worse you know we want to make it better
and what better way than to do that in a
nice safe environment right next to the
road where people in the village can
come walk to and not use the cars you
know it just it just seemed to me a
no-brainer really
and when Elizabeth first came up with
the idea I said to them look if you want
to do it we're all for it we'll go to
the community and see what they want if
they don't want it forget it and they
went there and I've just been so touched
by the support of the local community I
I just cannot believe it the numbers
today about wishing as well and how it
goes on there's you know the number of
applications with hundreds of them of
people supporting it and I'll just urge
you to to think again if you'd refuse it
please talk just let us help let's do
this for the community there's got to be
a way around this please whatever we do
I'll just ask that we try and get
something sorted because it is the least
bit of green belt if you like the lowest
where we're choosing Society is the
least impact on the Greenback that's
time thank you
uh thank you and does any members have
any questions
about the points raised
nope we'll move on to the next speaker
which I believe is going to be Carl
Langley
and thank you girl you got three minutes
thank you thank you so when uh I first
learned that Matthew and Lizzy wanted to
open a farm shop to sell local Farms
Produce Michelle and I decided to look
around at other Farm shops to try and
understand what was feasible and
achievable
um a number of these when we came to
look at them were located in Greenbelt
and on the open Countryside which meant
you know for us you know it made sense
that that would possibly be a
possibility
one particular note is a farm shop at
Stratton which is located away from the
main Farmstead development and is a
similar size and appearance to what's
being proposed in this instance
look at the approval of that Dome it was
interesting to notice that the planning
committee cited paragraphs 83 and 84 of
the national planning policy framework
as this appears to be relevant in this
case also
but it seems to have been emitted from
the report provided by the planning
officers on this occasion
as the planning officers May recognize
there's no available location within the
current settlement development limits of
cut thought for the creation of a shop
for the community
within their report the planning officer
acknowledges the community benefits that
such a shop would bring and also
recognize as the link with Farm
diversification
plus you may already be aware of the
contents of paragraphs 82 and 84 I would
just like to quote a specific sentence
that will take them from the planning
report for stretton
the mppf also states that sites to meet
local business and Community needs in
rural areas may have to be found
adjacent to or Beyond existing
settlements and in locations that are
not well served by public transport
in these circumstances it is important
to ensure that development is sensitive
to its surroundings and does not have an
unacceptable impact on local roads
as this development is intended to both
both be sensitive to surrounding area
and will not impact the roads negatively
I would respectfully that's a committee
to consider these points as well
uh thank you uh do any members have any
questions about the points raised
yeah counselor
audited The Stratton Farm Shop yes I
have yeah so it's really not in stretton
is it it's our new market actually it's
an open Countryside yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying because obviously you've
got the main road which is stressing
because they're five minutes away
I wondered if you've actually been there
to have a look yes of course I have yeah
yeah I enjoyed the cake as well just
before you ask
thank you you're welcome
and you know further questions I think
you can retake you see thank you
uh the next speaker will be Roger
Pendleton
which I believe is also a supporter of
the schemes
thank you got three minutes thank you
good afternoon German and member of the
council I'm talking mainly about the
quality of the view that has been raised
uh just to say the people of cuts off
living near The Institute enjoy fine
expansive views looking
to the South East over Chesterfield and
Beyond
uh from an elevation of 170 meters
because if you look at an OS map of the
area that precise point is 170 meters
above sea level
the cut-off Creamery proposal doesn't
threaten these views any more than a
growing sycamore tree would reduce the
view which does reduce the view from
further up the road
the photo montage of the impact of the
proposed Cafe shows quite clearly that
it is barely visible lying behind the
stone wall and at a lower elevation on
the road and besides being on Wheels it
can be reorientated
a point on the stone walls are part of
our cherished landscape and we are
grateful that Andrew Wood scrupulously
maintains and reinstates these even
though it costs them around ten thousand
pounds per annum in turn it provides
employment to local stonewallers
in conclusion there is little to suggest
that the quality of view from cutthop
are lessened by this proposal and we
should therefore approve it
that's all I've got to say thank you uh
any members have any questions and about
the points raised oh thank you if you'd
like to retake your seat and the final
speaker we have on this is uh John
Robinson
thank you you have three minutes when
you're ready thanks
Mr chairman I'm members of the committee
this is the application has a similarity
to a legal case there are Arguments for
and against you are the jury to decide
that matter of the strongest part
after the applicant's consultation with
our counselor
Council Martin Packer he decided and
requested it go to the committee
so the matter could be considered
thoroughly not just the officer's
decision
other counselors
you either the matters to consider
there's a economic development business
Health cleansing Community not just
whether some proposal is in the green
belt
these old these days all organizations
which include councils are encouraged to
be sustainable and diverse
this is exactly what this application is
about
one of the biggest problems this country
is facing at the moment is producing
more of what we need within the country
and also reducing the cost of what we
produce this is just a small step in the
con in this direction and Andrew Wood
has already made that point about the
movement to build
all the reasons why this application is
an exception within the definitions the
district's plan have been covered by the
previous speaker
if you turn down this application then I
am ensure that the parish council will
apply for a neighborhood development
order in conjunction with the
neighborhood plan which we believe will
soon be accepted as this order requires
a referendum judging by the present
support basis it would be soon be put
into practice
planning is also about schemes which
should benefit the community the
Brampton neighborhood plan does that as
explained by the previous speakers
over 65 members have supported this
proposal with only eight objections one
being an anonymous so doesn't count and
two from the same person one being which
is an addition and one supports the idea
and would use it
but it fills it in the wrong place
this shows that the application has a
large number in support
be approved
to meet the communities that the unit
one letter is particularly relevant and
I quote I care for my elderly mother in
the village and will be a huge boost to
her mental health and well-being to have
somewhere local to shop and socialize I
call on you as counselors to decide on
what is the right decision to make
having heard all the positive reasons
for approving the application thank you
thank you any members have any questions
about the points raised
no
thank you if you like to retail you see
uh College you will now have the
opportunity to put questions to the
officer about this officer about this
application
thank you do we have any questions for
officers councilor for awesome
three years is it not and we have
enforcement teams that can make sure
that if it was approved that they would
complying with whatever motions we pass
here today if we decided to is that is
that correct
a Time limited permission that's that's
correct
and you've heard this afternoon that if
the facility wasn't successful it would
be the intention to remove that that's
you need to consider in your assessment
chair but you've also heard this
afternoon that if the scheme is
successful it would be retained and
continue so I would
ask members to be guarded in terms of
that because if you were to Grant
permission for a Time limited three-year
period you would normally be doing that
to assess the impact of the development
whether after that you could
provided another permission that would
then continue that so I think this
afternoon you need to to strip the
application back to its basic elements
and
you need to determine the application in
accordance with the policies of your
development plan and
you've heard a lot that's happening
about other issues but the primary
consideration you have is the site lies
within the green belt where you have
very strong policies of restraint and
less very special circumstances outweigh
that and we've set out in the reporters
offices are assessment of that with that
needs to be where you you start from in
my advice to you if you feel that a
temporary permission for three years
outweighs any harm to the green belt
that you identify then of course you
could get permission for for three years
but I would advise members caution on
that chair because if the project was
successful I think you would be faced
with an application to then retain the
building in its current form on that
point
sort of two things come to mind about
key performance indicators there about
it doing what it says on the tin if it
was a three-year time limit application
at what point would it have to come back
here
to be reassessed for any
additional Works Etc
if you were minded worrying your mind
would have said about going through that
process if you're minded to Grant a
three-year temporary permission then you
would expect an application to come back
into the council for the removal of that
condition that would otherwise time
limit the permission
prior to that three years expiring
that would be a matter for the applicant
and if that wasn't the case in the three
years expect if you granted permission
for three years and that expired then
that will become a matter of the council
following it up as you say through the
enforcement process
so as it stands if this were to be
asked
um hypothetically speaking within three
years everything would have to be
removed anyway
if there was no application to extend it
if that's the the way that you were you
would granted permission this afternoon
that's right yes okay thank you
any other questions
professors
nope
uh right then uh thank you for that
officers um this is the final part of
the process our discussion on what we've
heard what we think and what we want to
decide oh and I would like to open the
floor for debate
uh Christine can just put his mouth
well that's all
that's all I'm minded that we should
really think about this
I understand the points about the green
belt but then we've got you know
diversification for farmers and a great
public good
counselor
food security is a serious concern in
this country at the moment and farming
in itself isn't a threat especially
Family Farms they're really struggling
and I think it's for people like
ourselves to try and make them as viable
as possible because
soon what we'll move to is a food system
where we get a lot of food miles it's
not locally sourced and produced when it
could have been if we'd have had a
can-do attitude to
Solutions such as this
the big issue here is encroachment on
the Green Belt but the green belt is
there to protect
land that would have otherwise be built
on
um unnecessarily
in this particular circumstance it's
quite clear that this is a temporary
building and has a lot of very is quite
a viable proposal that would have uh
positive impact locally as well as the
fact it's going to help a family keep
farming in Northeast Derbyshire
which is extremely important
so
taking into account what we said about
the three years
I would like to invite any
um contributions from other members or
officers about what key performance
indicators we could put in place
to the applicant
that we can find a way of them being
able to achieve planning today that
would make sure it's viable but also
equitable
uh Adrian
the advice we give us as planning
officers chair is is based on
the legal responsibilities that the
local planning Authority has to
determine applications in accordance
with a development plan unless material
matters content otherwise or or outweigh
that position so in this instance
Channel I'll come back to the point that
Council force made in a second if I if I
may but the starting point for you has
to be whether or not the proposal lies
in accordance with the policies of your
plan when when read as a whole and I
come back chair to the
primary issue in your officer's opinion
in this case is that the development is
proposed in the green belt where you
have strong policies of restraint and in
this instance the advice we're giving
you as officers is that the proposal
does not meet one of the exceptions to
developed in the green belt and so our
conclusion that it is
inappropriate development and that is by
definition harmful to the green belt in
our assessment chair we've then gone on
in the report to assess the level of
that time and we've concluded that there
is both Visual and spatial harm and
we're giving that significant weight in
in our assessment and then we go on to
discuss the the other material matters
that have been performed it's a very
special circumstances in our conclusion
is that they don't outweigh that
in terms of your assessment you need to
go through that same process
so I would urge members to go through
that same process now if you conclude
that it's inappropriate development then
you come on to the very special
circumstances that that counter the
force it and Council agar have been
talking about chat and then you must
consider whether they outweigh whatever
level of harm you contend there is to
the green belt and that's that's your
conclusion in terms of the point that
that councilor force it made share the
assessment of whether the project is
successful or not would not be a matter
for yourselves that that is a matter for
the parties you need to consider the
matter in terms of
um issues that you've talked about
um
diversification assisting the farm
um provision of a facility for local
people that that is what you need to to
weigh in the balance and you need to be
sure that in weighing all that any of
those other circumstances are not just
circumstances they are very special
circumstances and therefore we would
normally as officers encourage you to
put that in the context of not easily
replicated elsewhere so you need to to
to balance all those things in the uh in
in the way that you you come to your
conclusion
if you were to conclude that they did
outweigh
the harm to the green belt if you
include there is harm to the green belt
then you could put a three-year
temporary permission on that would
normally be there to allow the applicant
to show that their business has been
successful I would presume they would
come back to you in three years time
with their balance sheet saying it's
been successful it's it's um achievable
we've
um had this throughput and we've made
this amount of money and this is our
business plan going forwards and then
you could assess then if you wanted to
assess the issue of liability going
forward into that assessment just
whether you wanted to then Grant a
further permission
extending the three years in effect
I was actually thinking about more about
the environmental impact and the
assessment of that because if milk is
being moved down a couple of where the
gentleman said but a long way away and
that transport then is you know the
carbon that's being created whereas if
if it were possible for us today if it's
not already included I don't recall it
where there was exclusive sale of dairy
products from the farm only within that
shop that is already reducing food
mileage and carbon impact thus there is
a greater environmental
outcome by having that shop there than
removing the land you know is it as it
presently is and it's
um impact on the environment being used
for the growth of crop crops
so that's the um that's the that's what
I'm looking at there is well if if that
if that dairy product is being sold
locally and it's not being transported
all that way that far outweighs growing
let's say a third of an acre's worth of
grain there uh every year
in circumstances elsewhere in the
district we have
Place conditions on approvals for Farm
shops requiring the level of produce
within those Farm shops to be
provided from X or within a radius of we
do find them difficult to enforce
because we've all visited Farm shops and
the range of products often exceeds as
before this afternoon milk related
products or beef related products or
cereal related products that they often
um exceed that so from an enforceability
point of view we have found difficulty
in ensuring that but for example you
could condition that only produce
grown or developed on the farm could be
sold in the farm shop but it does have
those enforceability difficulties for us
and and I've had no concept I'm afraid I
apologize I have no concept of what one
million liters of milk looks like or who
it who it provides for um just no
concept of that so whether that could
all be kept within the farm shop and
avoid the trips to droitwich I Don't
Know But I've no concept of how that
that would work or how how 80 beef
cattle translate to to produce so but
you could
um if you were minded having gone
through all the other steps the planning
steps to to want to condition that to
achieve the reduction in the the carbon
footprint and that was one of your very
special reasons then you could place
those conditions on but I do have that
caveat that they are traditionally
difficult to enforce
thanks chair this is this is one of
those applications I hate gosh your
heart goes one way and your head goes
another
um in principle I I actually do support
this but what the officer says is 100
right it doesn't meet any of the
conditions for for building the green
belt
um the sad thing is if they've actually
put the processing plan there which
would have had major cultural need we
won't be having this discussion
um
yeah I mean
personally I would love to support it
and say yeah but I don't it's the case
if we don't follow the policies and I
mean looking at the neighborhood plan
which has been referred to several times
and no it's not enforced yet
first thing to ensure that any new
development in the parish whether it is
new housing conversion or existing
buildings or other development requires
no intrusion to the existing green vowel
um this is this is the problem you and
often the problem with with Naval plans
because they put things in black and
white then you have something that they
then want to make an exception of
um so yeah we've got a lot of support
from the village saying they want it but
we're also realistically having the
village saying at the same time saying
they don't want this to happen and if we
approve it and then we go with permanent
in 20 years down that will be a house
there
nothing's being given so we just don't
know that so it's a hard one
I loved support it but based on based on
what we've got it doesn't need any of
the criteria at all for building the
Green Valley
um
I'm in agreement with David on that it
is one of those
um
that your heart goes with the uh support
in it but unfortunately we've got to
look at the framework that we that we're
constrained by both nationally and
locally
um and I think it makes it a very
difficult decision
um but I've on that grounds I don't
think it mitigates
enough uh the intrusion into the green
belt
Saudi speakers I can't participate
further after they've spoken and
answered questions
right so we've got uh no more
contributors to the debate
um I've been heard everything today and
the official recommendation before us uh
what is the view of the committee on the
application I am now opening the floor
to motions
yeah
foreign
thank you
uh right the uh
on the floor we've got to accept uh
officer recommendations uh so we're now
going to take that to a roll call
thank you chair
councilor Cooper
counselor forces
for
councilor girl
four
councilor Hancock
for
councilor Hartzell for
councilor Jones for
counselor Lacy for
counselor
and councilor Rouse
four that's unanimous share the motion
has passed uh thank you
um that's the Tomato if you can leave
the chamber please thank you
thank you for your attendance and uh
thank you for all your comments
thank you
okay thank you David
yeah right if everyone's happy I'll move
straight on to the next application
um so this is uh application Ned 22
stroke zero one zero four two stroke a d
Wing width
right uh in line with the normal
practice time
I'm going to ask the planning
but to tell us about the any late car
comments and
implementation showing any photos and
plans of the site and allow the officers
attention again members unless you have
any points of order that you feel cannot
wait
uh could you please reserve these or any
questions about the process until the
end so I'm now going to review a hotel
where Graham Cooper is doing the last
presentation thank you
thanks chair we're just firing up the
presentation now
thank you Alice
all right then so this is an application
for advertisement consent for the
installation of four signs on the parish
rooms at wingworth two signs will be
vertically installed and the other two
positioned horizontally
throwing concerns raised by the case
officer and neighboring residents the
original submitted scheme has been
amended to remove any internal
illumination from the proposed signage
at one single late representation was
reported yesterday that was just
offering some officer commentary around
the scale of the proposed signage
there's been no third-party comments
there are no technical reasons why this
application should be refused
are the main issues as laid out in the
officer reports are the impacts on the
proposed advertisements on the character
and appearance of the site and the
surrounding Street Scene the impact on
public immunity and Highway Safety
thank you Alice
so this slide this illustrates the
application site shaded in Orange the
application site sits within the
settlement development limit for
wingwith
with open Countryside to the west of the
western New Road
you've got detached Residential
Properties to the north east and south
of the application sites
we've also got an established equestrian
development opposite the site along with
a recently constructed holiday Cottage
where they're set at a lower level than
the Hedge line which is on New Road the
land levels to the West Fall Away down
into the valley
so this is the location plan which has
been submitted with the application
you can see the site etched in red
hopefully there
the plan illustrates more clearly the
relationship between the site and the
neighboring properties you can see the
existing car park associated with the
parish rooms
just off on a limb to the right hand
side there
and how close it is to the existing
properties which surround it next slide
please
so this plan illustrates the position of
the proposed signage we've got two
vertical signs are proposed at points
six and eight on this plan
this is to the front and rear entrance
points of the building two horizontal
signs will be positioned at points one
five on the plan and these being at the
side of the main entrance on New Road
and one on the North Gable
thanks
perfect
so this plan this illustrates the design
of the proposed vertical and horizontal
signage
just to be clear the dimensions
Illustrated on this plan are for
illustrative purposes only and this is
just to show the difference between the
horizontal and vertical design of the
signage
next slide please
so this plan is a more detailed plan and
it illustrates the exact dimensions and
design of the signage the lettering will
be 1.85 meters in width and 0.4 of a
meters height
vertical design is just a 90 degree
rotated version of what you can see here
So the plan shows that the signage will
be constructed with internal lighting
but just to be clear the units will not
be switched on
this plan also confirms the final
Dimensions as we've discussed
the applicant has confirmed that they
will in the future explore Illuminating
the signage but this will be in
consultation with officers and Neighbors
and I've advised that a new permission
will be required to illuminate the
signage
and just to just make sure that that's
clear of included a condition ensuring
that the signs will not be illuminated
in any way included in the officer
recommendation
and the next few slides are just a
couple of photos taken from site that
members will have seen yesterday at the
virtual site visit this is taken from
New Road facing the north elevation of
the parish rooms and a horizontal sign
will be included in the elevation that
you can see there
this next slide is taken from the car
park to the rear of the parish rooms
and a vertical sign will be included on
the elevation next to the rear entrance
just to offer a bit of a way marking
into the building
and the final slide
this is taken from New Road and a
vertical sign will be installed to the
left of the door and to install we can
just about make out there
and a horizontal sign will be on the the
blank Gable you can see between the
doors and the small window it just helps
you know way Mark people into the
building and that concludes the
presentation
uh thank you
um
as well no speakers on this application
we will go straight to questions to what
the officers again I would like to keep
this part of the proceedings focused on
getting clarity about any point you are
not sure of so I would be grateful if
you could not move any motions at this
stage
do we have any questions for officers
okay
yes I would like to ask the officer are
these actually going to be hardwired
sort of may possibly be accidentally
switched on
uh or left
remote of any power supply
so I'm advised that they will connect
the signage up but they won't be
switched on so
you know we could include a note maybe
just to make it clear uh you know the
condition is there and it's enforceable
so if the lighted line is put on by
accident then
you know and I think that
if it is accidentally Pawn that might be
an interesting test to see what that
harm is because I know the parish rooms
are looking at some form of an
illumination for this signage but they
want to work in conjunction with us and
the residents because there has been
concerns about all the lighting on the
site but you know we have got conditions
saying that it it won't be illuminated
and that's that's all we can kind of
secure for you today
yeah I would like to think that it
couldn't possibly be turned on if they
come back then obviously
that's a different yeah different
question
[Music]
any other questions for officers nope
uh okay thanks for those uh I've been
heard everything today and the official
recommendations before us uh what is the
view of the community on this
application I am now opening the floor
uh to motions
oh well to debate sorry
counselor
um I'm a bit with Tony on this one I
think I think we need to make sure that
his it can't be turned on I think we
need some condition in there just to say
and and then let him bring it back and
whether we can stipulate something later
on that they can have so many lit up or
rather than I think eight sounds all lit
up on one building's a bit excessive to
be honest
um
yeah
no it's not like the building doesn't
stand out anyway is it
uh right members
um do we have a motion put forward with
this application
all right but yeah going with that I'll
second that
we need to do a roll call can we just go
to a show ends
we'll go for a show events
yep
just with the condition uh where am I
possible yes
yeah
uh right that brings us to the end of
all the uh decisions we got to make now
called the planning officers to explain
our next report automate appeals lodged
and determined
I could share this is a good raft of
appeal decisions that
um reporting this month and I'm taking
it all members are receiving the the
appeal decision so so that's a good
thing there are a few here chair would
just like to make reference to the first
is the first sorry chair do we want to
invite councilor Hancock back in he
probably doesn't know where finished oh
sorry you're not entirely sure he's
still here but we'll just go out and
just check he's left his pan
foreign
[Music]
first of all chair the the first appeal
lodged at paragraph 1.2 which is
and site that many members may be aware
of but it's the the West Hamley Ministry
so there's a enforced notes been served
on the activities there and that will be
heard in due course the the second
reference I do want to
um bring members attention to chair is
it's paragraphs 1.5 the four appeals
there they're all enforcement appeals
but they do go into some detail the
discussion that we've had this afternoon
regarding Greenbelt and
how the decisions of the inspectors have
been reached in all of those four cases
that who make interesting reading chair
and particularly the um
the appeal decision at cart ref also
discusses issues around impact on the
conservation area at
home's field but it does have other
applications elsewhere in the district
and also regarding the fallback position
which will often be be faced with so I
would if you haven't already I would
encourage you to have a look at all four
of those and read through for the new
race some very useful learning points in
terms of decision making
happy take any questions here but that
though just the points I was going to
raise thank you for that Adrian any
questions
nope right thank you
uh thank you members do we agree to note
the report
just show events yep okay uh I have no
urgent business so I'll now declare the
meeting closed thank you for your
attendance